Did you know that your brain sees more
than you do? Let me explain. In order for
us to understand and interact with the
world around us, our brain must process,
or make sense of, what the eye see.
Information travels from the eyes
through the brain getting processed
along the way. The first, most basic stage
of processing occurs at a region called
the primary visual cortex. Afterward, the
processing becomes increasingly complex.
It divides into two streams with
distinct functions: the ventral stream
flows along the lower region of the
brain. It is often called the what
pathway because processing in these
regions allows to identify what we see.
The dorsal stream flows along the top
region of the brain. It is called the
where or how pathway because it helps us
to identify where objects are and how to
interact with them. The dorsal stream
allows us to use vision to make precise
effective movements. One of the ways we
know about these two separate streams is
because of evidence from patients with
very specific brain damage. Sometimes
people can sustain damage to one visual
stream but not the other. One famous
patient known as DF lost function of her
what pathway in the ventral stream but
was still able to interact with objects
using the how pathway in the dorsal
stream. For example, she was not able to
describe the orientation of a slot she
was clearly able to see but was able to
reach out and insert a card into the
slot so even though she couldn't
perceive the orientation her brain could
use the information to guide action. This
condition is known as visual agnosia. The
reverse is called optic ataxia and it's
more rare but can also occur. Damage to
the how pathway in the dorsal stream
but not the what pathway in the ventral
stream means that optic ataxia patients
can't use objects correctly but can still
perceive what they are.
Researchers have also shown the same
separation between perception and action
in healthy participants by using visual
illusions that make objects seem larger
or smaller than they actually are. Take a
look at this image. When we look at the
circles the illusion tricks our ventral
stream into perceiving this one as
larger than this one even though they're
actually the same size. But when we reach
out to pick up a circle even if we
perceive it as larger than it is we are
able to grasp it based on its actual
size thanks to the dorsal stream.
Essentially, the illusion fools the
ventral stream but not the dorsal stream.
This separation between perception and
action in patients and healthy
participants shows that the two visual
processing streams and their functions
are independent. That being said in
everyday life it's rare you'd ever
notice the difference between vision for
perception and vision for action. The
dorsal and ventral streams work together
to help us perform daily tasks and
researchers are continuing to study the
exact relationship between the two. So
even though your brain sees more than
you do it's very good at integrating all
of your vision into one seamless
experience of the world and allowing you
to interact with it!